[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I hope you had a
glorious week I hope you enjoyed I hope
you're enjoying the show this year um
this is a big episode for us because
this is the first video look at that
we're actually talking about seeing us
wow this is great
as long as you're on YouTube yeah as
long as you're on YouTube you're
listening yeah you're still listening to
the Chris ask you watched listen to this
which is very important but you can also
then go subscribe to the YouTube and and
watch it as well later when you're home
from work and you have nothing to do
with your lives like me you know I wrote
down a whole bunch of stuff of stuff
that's going on and I want to always say
thank you to you you guys out there the
listeners I think I've said it a million
times but you got to because you're the
reason we're here the you that are loyal
and I see those same downloads every
Tuesday when they pop up immediately and
on my people are still listening thing
god I say that because I love it I love
doing this I love talking to people I
love learning about myself I love
opening up becoming more being more
vulnerable and watching my guests be
more vulnerable and that's what's been
really great a lot of people said don't
do video because they won't open up as
much you know I disagree completely
don't you Ryan oh yeah oh yeah I like it
so far it's weird like being on camera I
mean not weird for me maybe weird for I
am it's like what do i do what do I do a
lot of great stuff going on again I want
to say thank you you're subscribing tell
your friends get them to subscribe
patrons my patrons out there are
freaking wonderful I'll mention you in
the outro your names you know who you
are but everybody on there really
supports the show and when you give
money to the show it really it's you
know we're not like the biggest show out
there were not Rogan and you know he's
great I'm not comparing I'm just saying
you know we're the little caboose that
could and we want to really just launch
this thing we want to keep doing it and
make it grow
remember the little red caboose well the
caboose is the thing at the back that
doesn't the engines Oh engine yeah [ __ ]
thank god you're here I'm an idiot I
will be in Mexico in March the mole
Mexico for three days we're doing a
Smallville night some of the Smallville
guys are gonna be there I'm doing a live
podcast guys I'm saying it right now
you're hearing it live podcast in Austin
Texas this is gonna be pretty incredible
it's at a place called the north door in
Austin at 7:00 p.m. on March 31st on a
Tuesday night my guests exactly
so you know I'm from Shazam Chuck he's
been on the show before we're gonna take
down Austin so please get your tickets
I'm gonna tell you where to get those
tickets well here it says HTTP colon
slash slash inside of you
live.com it will redirect you get your
tickets twenty-five bucks if you get
them now also if you go to margin Walker
presents calm it will lead you to their
to its March an inmate are GIM so uh
yeah check it out it's gonna be a really
fun night I'm gonna get out there with
with Zack Levi and hopefully maybe I'll
have some shirts by then you know give
some prizes and really have a good time
I'm excited about it I'm not I'm not
nervous I'm excited it's just like I
like live live I don't know if I can
bring you I think it's too costly that's
fine
maybe we'll figure I'll just sit along
in the dark no you won't that's what
happens you just turn the lights off in
here just stay Jesus no great guest
today you've seen him as Superman you've
seen him in the legends of tomorrow
that's right he opened up I could tell
he didn't want to at first and then he
just kind of let it go and talked about
you know how he didn't really like how
his how he acted in a certain way and
you know maybe it was immaturity or was
getting old it was just sometimes life
kicks you in the ass and it makes you
wake up I've gone through it most people
do go through it or they be you know I
think if you don't have these
revelations or these or become
vulnerable or I don't know man it's it's
it's amazing where the hand of fate
takes you when you just let it and he
lets it out he tells you about the
adversity faces and I think you're gonna
really enjoy this one I haven't seen him
this open so I hope you guys enjoy it
let's get inside my buddy
Brandon Ralph it's my view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
welcome to my podcast this is Michael
Rosenbaum and this is inside of you and
today's guest
I love that look at that guess it's
taking pictures Brandon Ralph thank you
for allowing to be inside of you you
know you ask permission so I did a few
times mm-hmm
I didn't bug you right you didn't feel
like I was ever bugging you like [ __ ]
did you it could be a truth I appreciate
what I did notice was that you wanted to
make sure that I didn't flake and forget
which I appreciate because that happens
quite a lot
does it happen with actors with yourself
or does it happen with hosts of things
no no not with hosts I think it's with
guests you want to make sure you know
that that it's that it's happening I I
tend to worry sometimes that plans that
I've made are gonna are gonna fall
through with it somebody forgot or right
you know because I think with with the
cell phone people don't make concrete
plans well not only that but if you text
somebody you said yeah dude I'll do that
sometimes I just forget that I didn't
get my gammit intercounty of course I
wanted to do it I've had that where
somebody doesn't show up and then run
out and I have to sort of improvise it
happened right
you call yes but your car your special
guest who comes in and and you know sits
in when you're missing your guests like
they do on all the talk shows yeah I'm
usually that special guest
I'm usually that recurring guest hey
Rosie are you available at two o'clock
now what yeah yeah we want to be a guest
that obviously someone cancelled that's
why you're calling yeah well you could
do it yourself it's just different sides
interview different yourself thing if
someone doesn't show if I just go and I
just ask a question go over there sit
down and you'll just edit it did you
talk to my so you interview but you
interview a different side of yourself
different by the way yeah we're rolling
cameras and I ask some questions and I
do this and I I do that you know we
wouldn't be able to use the wide shot
gonna unless you know some CGI but you
get asked to do these things a lot you
get asked by people hey will you do
interviews what you do podcast yeah a
lot huh
yeah it's become one of the most popular
ways to to talk and and have a
conversation I I frankly enjoy them
much more exciting when I have the time
to sit down at length and speak about
things versus you know regular TV
interview or intends to be very five
minutes three minutes right quick and
also they have it they have an agenda
right they have their agenda for
entertainment and I have this thing I
have to plug and you know their canned
answers to a degree and yeah it's not as
it's not as creatively engaging and
exciting you seem I think you are you're
pretty much a private person your
private guy right you mean all over the
media doing things doing stupid things
right yeah getting yourself in trouble
you're not a partier you don't go out
and get drunk you have a wife you have a
kid I just throw ragers at my house for
agers yeah for myself
right yeah and my wife you know I but I
was wondering what do you do some list
because I'm sure in the media you just
heard about all the stephen amell stuff
and i was just listening to a little bit
but not all of it
well have I got about the first 25
minutes you almost hit the part where so
yeah I got it he had a panic attack oh
my god and then I told him I said look
I'll get rid of it you me just can it
and I'm like geez let me listen to it
you listen to it goes hey I want to come
back I want to finish it and it was
really important because all my
listeners and maybe more maybe people
more people will listen because you know
this is a guy that you look at you like
an actor he hit TV show he plays a
superhero he's beautiful looking great
body he even wrestles on the side he's
got millions of dollars how could this
guy get anxiety how could this guy get
you know people don't think about it I
mean most people like oh actors you know
this this whole thing you know they they
well they're getting paid a lot of money
they don't doing this guy was working 23
episodes of you you guys are doing all
these crossovers things and he hit a
wall
and I could tell when I was talking to
because they interviewed him before on
the show and he was just anyway he
decided look I'm coming back I'm gonna
do this and he was much stronger in a
great place and we talked about I let
him listen to what he had said and it
was nuts and he was and I let him know I
go listen you know people want they want
to do this thing on people people and
he's like yeah I go you ever call you
want to quote something you don't have
to he's like yeah immediately send me
back a quote read you know
tweeted he was like I was amazed by his
bravery
yes that's
brave of him to be open enough to have
that to to let it be a part of the
conversation which yeah you know the
stigma and all of that mental health
thankfully has has started to shift in a
lot more notoriety and and and news and
an exposure you know yeah
it's something we all we all have to
deal with every day when we wake up yes
how are you going to attack the day are
you conscious of how you're going to
attack today do you just wake up how do
you live life you know that's a good
segue into do you feel like you're
spreading yourself too thin ever do you
ever feel like you ever look at your
wife because in the interview he says
you know my wife yeah she's like hey I
wanted to go see someone
yeah I mean he's not doing anything for
two days he's not eating he's on the
couch he's it I heard that but yeah do
you ever get like holy [ __ ] man I played
Superman and now I'm on a show I'm
playing you know a big character is I
don't want anybody to see like the
vulnerability to the side of me that
they'll be like oh he's not capable of
playing this role he can't handle it if
they if you see any weakness you know do
you ever feel like that or have you in
years where I I know matter how nervous
you are or exhausted or whatever it is
you just suck it up and pretend that
you're absolutely fantastic I don't
think I always suck it up and pretend
that I'm absolutely fantastic if I'm
tasked with that in an interview and to
go on and promote something yes I will I
will do that but I mean what you're
asking is multiple answers and pen and
aspects I do that question yeah I would
say that the end of my run as Superman
in Superman Returns that did not that
that that did not pan out the way I
thought it was going to the way everyone
around me thought it was going to and so
I had to really come to terms with a lot
of that I mean there was no sequel you
know the movie was widely well reviewed
people like to see like the movie but it
you know made almost 400 million dollars
worldwide but that wasn't enough and it
was a very slow fizzle out of the
possibility of a sequel over the next
two three years and I did my I did
everything I could do that I thought in
my in mmm in my world to help make it
happen which is a story for another time
or this time uh but but war to mental
health and we should go back if we want
on that but you know I I think at that
point in my life I still didn't know
that I had that I was anxious that I had
that what anxiousness really was or that
I had it that anyone could experience
anxiety yeah did you believe it I mean
you believe that we just did you ever
see anxiety jorssy I don't think this is
ever let it in you know there's a
there's a whole thing about go back and
look at my childhood anybody's childhood
and we all grow up a certain way
believing certain things and seeing the
world in in their way and I pretty much
saw rainbows and hearts and rainbows and
made everything that I didn't want to be
that wasn't hearts and rainbows into
hearts and rainbows it's called
bypassing right so I grew up in a
culture of bypassing spiritual bypassing
using God or using something else to
Aaron's good it's gonna it's gonna be
okay because just give it to God and and
it will you know everything will be okay
because of that right which is a very
can be very calming right it's a ways it
like okay don't worry about this but but
that catches up to you but eventually
right um because then you're only living
life in in in white and life is black
and white you can't have one without the
other
right it's essential for life yeah and
you know through through multiple career
experiences and showing me that I have
an opportunity to learn more and through
my wife Courtney Ford who's you know
been an amazing help that guide in in
finding balance because she was with you
through that whole thing yes she was
with you if she if you didn't have her
when you had Superman Returns right yeah
because you met her in 2002-2003 Green
yeah that's great closer but you know I
always think how do you get through
things yeah
so many things death you know you're
supposed to be on the sequel's
and then that didn't pan out yeah and if
you don't have anybody to vent to or
really go deep and be vulnerable and
real and you just deflect like fine I'm
fine go I've drink or I'll go out and
party you're just prolonging the
inevitable what's happening is
distraction distraction distraction and
all of a sudden three years later or two
years later a month later you start to
feel things and you don't even know
where they came from well why don't I
feel this why did I get so upset about
that why was my response to you have no
idea then it's lost in translation you
don't even know why you're upset and you
then through whatever therapy or you
realize it's coming for all from that
all these things that I kind of tucked
away yes I mean that's that's what I
found so it's nice that I you know I was
doing some reading and I do that
occasionally but um reading but just I
noticed Courtney was the theme the
Courtney was the sort of a running theme
that was just like I see how important
she is to you
i I very very openly speak about it yeah
at this point in my life because I
understand the great value that I that
I've received the lessons that I've that
I've been able to to to learn from her I
mean we've both we've both learned from
each other but I but I seen from my
perspective I see that I see the
devastate that I was experienced in my
life up into that point yeah as far as
an understanding balance in in life and
you know she knew me she knew me best
then she knows me best now and so going
through that whole trauma of Superman
Returns the end of Superman Returns was
a long drawn-out process of me and
denial for much of it and thankfully I
guess I didn't I didn't lean on drugs or
alcohol yeah partying I've played World
of Warcraft endlessly I see that you
know yeah and that was my addiction and
then you know a few other games along
the way but but that was where I lost
myself and spent way too much time it
took me a long time to come to terms
with that that that was an addiction to
beat the game
[Laughter]
there's no beating it and is there not
I've ever played no you can't beat it
just goes on and on no it goes on and on
forever right right as it's designed to
do and you know that what that was my
that was my therapy I was your question
right right and but it wasn't helping me
you know it was it was a coping
mechanism but it wasn't teaching me
things until I finally came you know had
several experiences where I had to come
to terms with that and and so she was
she was part of that now I have a better
understanding of what happened then
looking back I can go okay I took way
too long to get this point but finally I
achieved that level up as far as balance
my next phase was realizing what I had
messed up where where I had screwed up
Luke was the screw-up
the screw-up was still learning what the
screw up as the screw up was that
deflecting right what was deflecting but
why was I deflecting and and and in the
deflecting I had built up this ego of of
who I was and that's also it was fear
before ways deflecting out of fear okay
so I was deflecting out of fear because
I played Superman I jumped I he this
huge to the front of the line I'd done
auditions and I'd been on stuff before
but I really jumped to the front of the
line when I did that movie yeah and then
I wasn't given what I thought I was or
had earned I wasn't getting offers isn't
that kind of an EFT way of looking at
things cuz I know yeah because we feel
like well we deserve this yeah very
deserving and it's like it's hard to it
is ego and it's hard to imagine like
it's a that takes time to change your
way of thinking doesn't a very long time
I I was told by my you know
representatives and everyone they
thought it was gonna be a big deal right
that's what happens you do a big movie
and then you do other well then they
tell well I read that they actually your
agent took you on because like you look
sort of like resemble Christopher Reeve
so I'm gonna having my back pocket cuz
he's destined to play that role is that
sort of why he became your agent well
originally that was what he said to me
then but that I no longer what that
agent dropped me
after I got after I fired a soap opera I
was on back in 2001 anyway so they
missed out on that they sure did but
that didn't happen when well the only
offers I was getting more horror movies
which I didn't which I love the way I
look around you Fright Night I got
Dracula over here Rudy isn't a horror
movie but you know yes it's a wonderful
movie and all these other offers and
things for projects that I didn't that
weren't in line with what I wanted to do
not a lot but they but what offers were
coming and worth for things that I just
had no interest in and I didn't see them
moving my career forward and the path
that I wanted I had to audition for
things and there were things that came
very close that there that I was working
with on the studio that just didn't they
didn't pull out if they were in
production and it didn't happen a couple
other things that just didn't happen but
by and large I was not a qualified
auditioner who is it's the worst thing
in the world it's advice better now I
feel like I'm better now I have more
confidence in myself and many other
things that kind of help make that
better right but I was I was not a good
audition er except for things that I was
really right for right which is why you
get the things you're really right for
anyway so I I didn't do the work I I
didn't read scripts well enough I didn't
I I was I my foot was halfway out the
door every time I was going in so all
right then I was probably creating a bad
reputation for myself with casting
offices and and producers and things and
so but I was in denial of all this
fervor for for quite a while and I had
great opportunities thankfully that came
along you know with Zack and Miri and
Kent Smith you know and and Scott
Pilgrim we were talking about that yeah
loves that I got to see that that's
really a lot of my friends have seen
they love that so I got to see that yes
that's a class worthwhile movie all
right I'm gonna check that and then with
Chuck and so I had things you know
thankfully kept me afloat and learning
along the way but it wasn't until I
really until I really understood that I
needed to start again that I needed to
relearn things and relearn how to not in
relearn but I had to go back had to go
back and and actually learn how to
audition for myself and
reengage myself and really become part
of the process and fully it's looking
back I can call it surrender I can say
that I had to surrender to the process
and surrender to the fact that I had to
audition and became disciplined it
sounds like yes I started to work hard
and so that started you know the first
thing that started was happens I after I
took on that mentality was I got the
pilot the the sitcom that I did called
partners in 2012 and that was a
wonderful experience and would love to
be still doing it to this day but that
we did 13 episodes and that was the end
of that then shortly after that was some
opportunity for for for arrow and I you
know they they I brought in a had a
meeting with the producers but then I
had to go back and I read with a
wonderful Emily Ricketts and and did a
chemistry test with her and so I had to
prove myself that's the thing you always
you have to prove yourself and I'm like
listening you know it's funny because
sometimes I think I'm gonna have nothing
in common with people and then you start
talking I think we all have things that
are in common like there is an ego ego
is such a big part of everyone's life
that they probably ruin a lot of
opportunities and I remember I had
opportunities but it was he goes whose
lack of discipline I don't want to go
learn this I I just sort of embarrassing
if I look back I'm like you [ __ ]
pompous little [ __ ] and for you to go
you know you have an audition with uh
you know Tom Hanks or something I mean I
worked on that one but uh you know
Good Will Hunting and Saving Private
Ryan and I remember those like that
night before party and I was a kid I was
like 26 and I was like I'm gonna go I
didn't give a [ __ ] like guy I wasn't
mature and by the way maturity isn't
something that is in my vocabulary
but I'm very responsible and you know it
takes time you say it takes time to sort
of like look back and go hey this is
this is where I was [ __ ] up this is
this is why and you said you learn you
relearn things I've talked about this
before but I I wasn't real earning I had
I had to learn all these things I had to
learn all the things that I didn't learn
as a child and so there's a lot of
growing up and I've done
in the last the most grown-up I've done
in the last year and a half of just
between doing this podcast and like
talking to folks like you and and sort
of digging deep in like it's funny
because I'm watching you're like there's
still things that you're figuring out
we're all figuring out but when it when
you look back and you think you know I
deflected I started playing Warcraft my
wife's doing this did you do you
remember even like having any breakdowns
any emotional moments any like crying
spouts you know bouts of like just like
God what's the matter with me I'm
emasculating myself you know did you
ever feel like that yeah I mean I'm not
gonna go into detail because that's a
you know but but there was a moment and
that was the moment when I when I when
things started to change
crying sobbing on the floor because I
was I was shown I was I finally I find
it allowed myself to come I was in a
vulnerable enough place I guess to come
face to face with with how people saw me
so I had that you have this vision of
who you are right and then there's how
people see you and when those two things
are incongruent when they don't come
together they don't match up you look in
the mirror and what's looking back at
you is other person's reflection of who
you are it's like what wait a second no
no there for a long time you go they're
wrong right they're on it are they're
wrong it's not me right
I Know Who I am but if you really allow
that to see that cycle can be
devastating oh whoa whoa I was I was a
real idiot I sincerely hurt people
and I made an incredible amount of
mistakes but I'm a good person and I
mean well so that was part of my part of
my ego is well I'm a good person I mean
well I'm doing I'm doing this to help
somebody but some people sometimes
people don't want help or they don't
want to help that you are giving them
you can still hurt somebody by helping
them you're kiddin you can still you can
do them and I can't give you an example
right now but definitely happens that
you can have good intentions but still
hurt people and I was in a cycle of of
that to a two degree of not
understanding that I was doing that
right and then you were all of a sudden
hit with it
remember like I'm a martyr right but I
was I was just kind of screwing some
stuff and then it became a reality to
you what you had been doing like and
really genuinely honest with yourself
and that's sort of when the breakdown
happened yeah that's sort of when you
were like I'll tell you what I get
itself like self-loathing yes like you
know when I've had interviews like
people don't love themselves I get it
yeah get it because I've been there yeah
I know what it's like you know what I
only don't like myself I actually
remember looking in the mirror I'm not
kidding did I tell you this right no I
remember looking in the mirror and going
who the [ __ ] are you man like it like if
anybody was filming they'd think I was
crazy person and maybe I was maybe I am
[ __ ] are you dude like who the [ __ ] are
you and I really look at myself it
wasn't like I was doing this all the
time who's just like this would happen
occasionally every couple months I just
go you know wash my face and I brush my
teeth and I kind of look in the mirror
and I go I'd look closer look I just I
was trying to put it together I really
don't know myself I don't what do I do
like what do I do I don't have Courtney
I don't have you know so mine was well
baby I was like going [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna take care my said I want to
find me and I want to live the last 20
30 40 50 years going hey now I got a
grip of who I am and that by the way
that's that's horrible I mean I've had
those breakdown moments I've had those
breakdown moments in the shower like
it's a comedy like if people were
filming you to be like air supply and
I'm on my knees naked with water around
me and I'm just balling and I'd start to
laugh after the cry thinking of that I'm
all out of love with you you know and
dude that that [ __ ] hits home it
doesn't if you just pay attention to it
long enough you you'll have to address
it yeah that's self-awareness you know
we look in the mirror all the time and
see if we have you know anything in our
teeth or what our hair looks like but
we're not really looking and seeing
what's behind into the eyes what's who's
there who's in control is our brain in
control or use our higher nature in
control are we just a mammal or are we a
human
it's the difference that sets us apart
from pretty much all mammals is that we
have this ability to think on a higher
level how self-awareness in our
prefrontal cortex what sets us apart is
that we know that we know that we know
we don't just do things we we can
understand our or aware of what we're
doing
or what we can be we can be aware what
we're doing most of humanity is not
aware of what they're doing they're just
doing it wrong on every once in a while
they check in autopilot what's going
through the motions its autoplay all
done that and tell these big moments
either happy or sad yeah hits you anyway
whoa and it and you you're forced to
either step out of that autopilot or not
but when you're able to step out you go
holy [ __ ] this is what is real and what
isn't real what am I in control of them
what am I not in control of yeah what is
this human experience what am I here for
what am i doing why am i working 14
hours a day yeah not seeing my family or
what would have to make money maybe two
there's always reason am I making money
why am i doing any of this why am i from
my child for my we're all searching for
the purpose and then we're going a
little bit from and Telus but this is
all part of it you know what is the
purpose of what is the purpose of life
and I certainly don't have an answer for
every one inside of you is supported by
better help online counseling you're
talking to someone who goes to
counselors who gets goes to therapy who
tries to do everything to improve his
life that's me this is the perfect
sponsor for our show we all know that
sometimes life is stressful it's hard it
is no matter who you are I don't care
who you are and we could all use help
and some people want private help and
they want you know sometimes it's too
expensive
better help offers licensed counselors
who specialized in issues including
depression anxiety complicated
relationships grief all this stuff Ryan
we get overwhelmed right what do you do
for when you're overwhelmed what I'm
overwhelmed yeah I mean I do you think I
have a scotch as what I do right and
that's probably not the way to go
probably not now you've got to deal with
things you can connect privately with a
counselor through text chat phone and
video calls and get help on your own
time TRO and pace at an affordable rate
inside of you listeners will get 10% off
the first month with discount code
inside it's it's it's a good deal it's
it's I think everybody needs a little
therapy a little help and better help
online counseling is the place to go
that's better help.com slash inside
remember inside of you listeners get 10%
off their first month with discount code
inside why not get help better help calm
slash inside inside of you is brought to
you by squarespace our dear friends of
Squarespace Ryan isn't it nice to know
that with Squarespace you could turn
your idea to a cool website it's amazing
these guys at Squarespace they have
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers so they're there
for you cuz most you're not gonna know
where to go
these guys are gonna give it its all
right there for you do you understand I
like that 24/7 award-winning customer
service man that that's right there that
stands out mm-hmm ready to start your
new business make it stand out get
started with Squarespace think it dream
it make it with Squarespace head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch use the
offer code I owe you to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com enter code
I owe you you're getting something now
tell my purpose purpose isn't just
something you're born with
and maybe you are born with it but
you're just not aware of it most people
aren't aware of their true purpose their
true calling and it's usually the hand
of fate or whatever happens throughout
life eventually you get to a place
hopefully young enough where you're like
this is what I'm destined to do I'm
destined to maybe I'm destined to just
talk to people and open up and help
other people who are listening maybe you
know my real destiny lies and I mean
whatever but sometimes that takes a long
time and I think it's taken me a long
time yeah it's a double-edged sword I
think because you can you can kill
yourself pursuing your purpose in the
pursuit of your of purpose and and the
belief that there has to be a purpose so
great purpose in the pursuit of of of
purpose and meaning in life we do a lot
of bad things sometimes
I mean villains have purpose mm-hmm and
they want to validate their life or
feelings people who have that universe
long enough to call villains you know
right um I've played enough bad guys to
know that you you have to believe that
in what you're doing in order for it to
come off her authentically that's the
world that they live in and for me not
only for me speaking only for myself I
am experiencing what it is to be human
and that is my sole purpose how do you
do that not sole purpose it's the
fundamental purpose what do you do to
achieve that obviously you know you
can't just go to work and be an actor
and and come home and there's got to be
other things that you know like charity
charity stuff whatever it is that make
you feel something make you feel human
interaction connection presence all that
stuff like is there certain things that
you like this is the most important and
I'm not sacrificing this this is gonna
happen I'm gonna continue doing this and
you know what is that the biggest rule
or attachment that I have to any any
kind of rule or structure is my father
so that's number one and then I'm then
I'm a husband and teammate to Courtney
and we have that unit and then extends
to my family my my parents and my
sisters and my brother and friends and
what have you but I have to be here I
have to support Leo that is my number
one yes no my number one thing in life
that's purpose man that and he it's a
dual per I mean he I learn as much from
him as he's learning from me if not
learning more from him through that
experience but it's here to experience
life right now I chose to have a child
so I'm experiencing a life to see my to
see myself reflected I am seeing a
reflection of all of my flaws I see on a
daily basis the Tron
was that I have unresolved trauma that I
have in my life that I'm propagating
propagating on last minute to my son and
I can see that go oh I don't want to do
that
that was a learned behavior from my
family or from society and I don't
choose to continue to put that out into
the world and to give that to my son
I want him to be free of those foibles
those sins of the father and mother what
have you so I just can't imagine of
having that much much sin you seem like
such a great guy like I know these are
subtle things these are little things
along the way that you're like oh he's
learning that that's from me or that's
from this I uh you know I feel horrible
I don't want him to but you've got to
remember that we're human were
definitely not perfect and he's gonna
evolve into something and you give him
the love you give him whatever attention
that's probably you do the best you can
you have to know that like at least I'm
learning that like do the best you can
as long as you know it was the best you
could do you know in that moment and I
even give credit to my parents I'm like
going that you know hey you just really
didn't know how to be a certain way and
I forgive you and I'm moving on and I
love you
just acknowledge your fuck-ups
acknowledge your fuck-ups
which means when Leo gets to be 20 years
old he's a Jo blah blah blah and you
vote good you know you're you know
hopefully he won't say [ __ ] but I
would and then he's like I'm like chris
farley right now it's about saying you
know what leo you're right about that
I'm gonna be honest with you I wish I
would have done that I apologize for
that
I'm telling you just any kind of
acknowledging something from a parent
because they're always perfect there on
the pedestal they don't [ __ ] up there my
parents were just I thought they were
[ __ ] perfect everything they said
politically they said so-and-so is
having a fair down the street there are
not good parents or this I believe them
all then I woke up one day I go are you
[ __ ] look at you
you guys are more half than the others I
think that there was definitely like a
good look it's how you're raised but I
remember looking at my dad Lee
never drank smoked everything do you
know nothing no pot no I mean almost
nothing and it was until I was 21 and I
was a at his old dentist's office in
Long Island yeah my dad just was he
always like just kind of like break down
the line just didn't really do much is
your dad used to walk around naked are
you kidding me I'm like what so there's
some things you don't need to tell your
children my was like my dad's like yeah
yeah what
later on he started to open up a little
but I think that as long as you're just
honest and you do the best you can and
you acknowledge your faults and your
flaws that then I think that's what he's
gonna really admire it's it's something
when you don't when you sit there and go
I never did that you're wrong yeah I do
I have a feeling you listen to your
child you're calm you kind of just how
old is Leo seven seven so you know we do
our best to take responsibility and say
I'm sorry it's a very important practice
for us to to admit when we have made
mistakes parents make mistakes everyone
makes mistakes and teaching him to be
responsible for his own mistakes is a
big thing it's important to us you know
you say he can't imagine me doing too
much wrong or what have you but I have a
I had a I had a I'm like a zero to 60
zero to 50 anger sometimes when when
something wouldn't be right with not
just him but but road rage and that kind
of thing which I had a challenge with
years ago and I that reaction now is has
been something I'd become aware of it's
you start with awareness that you're
doing something and then you go okay I'm
doing I might stop it every time but I'm
becoming more aware that you don't like
this about your don't like it it's does
a servant understand where it's coming
from I am doing it and you start to
dissolve those things and the same thing
with there are a lot of frustration as a
as a as a parent why doesn't the child
sleep why doesn't he do this why you
know there's there's it's it's a form
it's very challenging most challenging
time in my life probably and so you can
look at those things that you're doing
that or not ideal and you can
work to shift them because I want the
experience not only for him but for me
also because I'm not setting myself a
bath a good day if I'm frustrated
continually frustrated by a child being
a child that is that is an irrational
attachment for me of a child to be
perfect and I hadn't there's the whole
perfectionism that was in that I had
aspect of it but I want to go back to
because it's all wrapped it go back to
the road rage I don't get it go back to
my first and foremost attachment and
most important thing to be taken care of
is my son and experiencing the world and
I experiencing the universe I'm
conscious being and I get to experience
what it is to be human and what it is to
interact with life so in order to do
that effectively for me I have to find
joy to find joy wherever I can I don't
always remember this listen this is a
prize is a new practice for me and I am
working on it continually but there and
it's challenge when you have impeachment
trials and what's happened in Iran and
and all everything in the wildfires how
do you find joy when there's all this
tear these terrible things happening in
the world I think they're probably
always gonna be terrible things
happening in the world for a very long
time so either we're always completely
stressed about it and worrying about
that and trying to stop those things
should try to stop those things always
but we also have to be able to find joy
where we can do those things and find
joy yeah have the moments of of despair
and loss don't gloss over it don't
pretend it doesn't and these things have
been happening for a long time sack it
for all of time my dad similar things
things were worse now right he's like
you kidding me Vietnam we just didn't
have it on phones and everywhere in
front of you it all the time there was
horribleness going on and what does it
matter if it was better or worse it's
still happening and and and and it's
going to I think it's probably going to
continue to still happen I hope not
until we as human beings as sentient
beings can find a better way to balance
it and to experience it so that when
there's a trauma we don't fully ly throw
away our belief in
positivity and good things happening
just because this terrible thing is
happening and and when this wonderful
things happening not just throwing away
the fact that terrible things can can
happen yeah
but finding that balance and being okay
with it and a lot of spiritual teachings
talk about this
it's the that's the middle way correct
definition but but there's but you have
to find balance that both things can
exist and it's okay that both things
that exist I don't think you can ever I
don't know if we'll ever extinguish if
if if we're to ever extinguish darkness
then there's only light and if there's
only light how can you know anything
else I mean there many philosophers
talked about this idea and young black
and white joy and I'm getting into the
weeds here that's all right I like the
weeds but finding joy and how I so what
I try to do on my on my work is go to
work and enjoy my time on set how do you
do that because the end product you
don't know what the end products gonna
be and I had to go into this you're also
talking about lost so we're going back
to that loss of my family for the last
five years and the character they played
for six years as you may not know I I
filmed my last episodes as in the air
over sand and as Ray Palmer and that was
a very traumatic event for me it was not
something I was expecting it was a
shocking like the day of they told you
the day of filming yeah hopefully they
know it was before we started production
but it was not well handled and and so
that has been something I'm still my
wife and I are both still working
through had been a huge transition time
for us those last eight nine ten months
and and so going how is it gonna find
the joy in that knowing this thing was
gonna end looming but I but I worked to
to just be with my crews become my
family and my cast been my family and an
experience that and just be there in the
interactions with the people and how do
you do that you have to have awareness
you have to check in on yourself a good
where every morning what is my brain
thinking wait wait where am I am I am I
am a repetitive thought about something
I might say am I having an aunt an
automatic negative thought that's
happening and also yeah you let the
things spiral and if you go insert the
way and you start I remember dealing
with things and all it you could see it
it's on your face like okay what are we
doing it's like the resentment aren't
these people it's something that
happened that they have nothing to do
with and and there's nothing they can do
and so it's sort of a waste of energy
and but but to be able to look at that
go alright alright this is what this is
that's that's maturity that's hard
that's the work of life so you have to
have all these experiences in your life
that help you teach you at some point
that that's the way to enlightenment to
freedom to to freedom from this
autopilot so we're born we don't have
autopilot we're taught autopilot by
society by our fire family we're open
we're open beings in that first stage of
life but what you have to be able to
function yeah you you if the world is an
acid trip and you've no structure as a
baby you don't have stripe you know I
don't know if it's like an acid trip but
no sir I don't know what anything is
there's a name for this what's language
I'm calling this this this is the color
blue we have to do that in order to then
experience the things right but you
learn that behavior you learn that
autopilot from you mostly from your
parents and from society but then you
have to unlearn that well you it sounds
like when after the whole Superman thing
you know you think thank God in a way
because let's say the sequels happen you
would have been you wouldn't have
changed you would that would have lives
on like a freaking cranberry song who
knows you know who knows but the fact
that it is really broken down in the bad
way or lashed out or done some other
thing cuz I wouldn't have had you know I
wouldn't have had the experiences I did
have the loss yeah that I did have to
help how much actually think you are
from that experience and growing and
figuring all that out in those [ __ ]
moments where you're just sobbing and
growing as by the way you won't that old
when that's when this happened 25:25
yeah I thought I knew everything of
course we always do it's crazy but look
what the whole thing you told me about
this cuz I don't know much about this
with the atom
you know another character in the comic
books ends up in the comic books they
take over that character that's what I
read online is that true yes in the in
good thing in the world Ray Palmer gets
lost I can't remember exactly where it
gets lost in the multiverse or in
something I was mixing that up with with
the aunt with a man but uh but he he
disappears anyway but he leaves his belt
behind which is in the comics how he has
the power to shrink and this young man
takes over takes over Ryan Choi becomes
yeah I mean okay that's in the comic
books but it's something was working and
everything's great and the ratings are
great and everybody look who gives a
[ __ ] if he gets lost it you let him get
lost the last steps am I wrong here cuz
I don't know how this works well that's
not so there's a lot of rumor that flies
around because you know these things are
put out there and and for whatever
reason they don't have a there's it's
not my I'm it's not my place to to
really speculate or or plans you could
you know I think characters are put out
there to see how what the response is
and what happens and that's not what
happens with with with Ray in the end I
think I'm fine saying that he doesn't
get lost into the multiverse it's not
we're not following the comic book
structure right but if they ask you they
weren't gonna come back for this thing
in the next season or whatever I don't
know down the road if you're not gonna
be on the show anymore I mean would you
would your ego then take over or
sometimes I don't think if he go it's
like no I don't wanna do anymore
yeah that's a tough thing yeah I've done
that we're like come back I'm like I
don't want to not not for that with me I
don't want to come back because I was
that guy yeah so I'm not gonna come back
in some other universe I don't know what
the [ __ ] going on and by the way it's
great it's a lot of great stuff I'm just
saying there's another Lex and it's me
and it's like it's this is not what I
need to do yeah I came back for a season
seven I came back for season 10 for the
finale I wanted to is great for the fans
you know and there's a lot of rumors and
stuff there was always like oh he left
the show damn it Kevin Smith says he
left to show one more [ __ ] time I love
you Kevin I said it but I'm like I
didn't live I mean technically my
contract was six years I talked about
this six years I stayed on until seven
seven years I did 160 something episodes
and then I said hey I'm gonna go do
whatever and of course people like oh
you look of course no matter what I do
it's not gonna be as big as Smallville
so I went off to do things that I love
yes I want direct I want to do this I
want to my family I wanna yeah what is
he doing blah blah blah he left
Smallville what would they come back
well [ __ ] you you're the one is selfish
telling me what I should be doing [ __ ]
you
so I'm not angry but what I'm saying for
you is if you are come back because you
love it and it's great oh this is
interesting
then that's what you do it for of course
but if you're like you know on I did
this for fart with five years five
seasons on legends and then I season on
arrow 100 over 100 episodes is the
carrot well I'm saying is do you think
you'd go back uh that's kind of a bridge
that I will decide to cross when I get
there yeah there there's a there's a lot
there's a lot wrapped up in that answer
I'm sure there's probably a little
resentment you said you didn't like how
you how things sort of uh you know
that's by the way I really appreciate
your candor and just sort of your just
just being able to just you know feel
and say that you know these are feelings
whether they are they're necessarily
right to someone who watches the
podcaster with someone who looks at your
interview you can't say everything that
everybody wants you to say you can't
feel like it so sometimes you do
scissors trying to live for other people
and be what other people think I should
be my [ __ ] challenges worried about
what people think of me thank you
that is the hardest thing because you
want everybody to be happy you want
everybody to be you know like you you
wanted you of course you want everybody
but at the end of the day it's like I'm
just gonna really try to I'm gonna [ __ ]
up I am going to [ __ ] up a trauma so
essential to life but it's essential and
I do a lot I know now and hopefully if
you love me or you like me and I say
something you don't like you know go Bob
Bok Kim you go alright well that's his
opinion or that's how he felt in that
moment so you know it's it's it's tough
it's it is tough and like a lot of
people on the outside will always say
you know the thing you always hear is
like you know they're lucky oh my god
they don't have a right to feel anyway
and I'm like I I have great full of [ __ ]
I might live in a house I I'm able to do
great things I'm blessed beyond reckon
I'm
if it all ends now I'm I died I say hey
man I
I had whether I had the opportunity I
had the I had everything in front of me
whether I used it to my best you know
capabilities probably not I'm learning
to do that now and helping other people
and which makes me feel good but I don't
know anymore I was going with them it's
okay it's okay to screw up yeah by the
way and but I appreciate and to see
people I think it's important for people
to know that we're fallible you know I
you know we for me putting up the
playing the character Superman I put a
lot of pressure on myself to to to live
up to that expectation I mean I was
always I was already a you know the a
boy scout and didn't do a lot of crazy
things anyway but I made sure that once
I got the role that I was not that I
protected the image not only of myself
but of the character integrity and it
was very important to me to have the
character have integrity and it's a
balance any way of trying to showing
perfection and and then showing that you
know life isn't about being perfect and
I think it's important for people to
know that you know that it's not always
a you know better on the other side you
know we we have this image we have this
view of who people are and what they are
we imagine what their lives are like and
we we project and we want to live that
life because it's better than ours
always and you have to come to terms
with the fact that to find happiness you
have to be okay with where you are well
this is your life this is real and
surrender to to your experience some
days are good some times are bad for
everybody yeah I I tend to do that I
will look at like my friend Canton
Indiana with his three kids in his house
and you know I don't know how it sounds
I just um there's this Envy there's this
this feeling of man
I won't say it out loud because god I'm
sure he wishes that he'd be on a hit
show when he goes out some people
recognize him and he does all these
things he goes to Laker games and but
deep down I'm thinking life's awesome
he's got three kids or in the Midwest
kids are drinking out of garden hoses
you know they go to maybe go to a
Walmart together
well I'm serious there's there's certain
friends that I look at that I'm like I
mean it's so cliche it just doesn't
matter what you have in terms of you
know money or fame it's just I mean it
just doesn't you hear it all the time
and you're lucky when you have it you
have all these things that's what you do
with it but also I mean you think about
the happy moments happy moments when you
just connect with someone he just it's
not about the money it's about two
people going this is a great moment
this is [ __ ] I can just feel this
this is you and me this is uh this is
beautiful or witnessing something really
nice and it's very hard and we get
caught up in all these dances it's
experiences man and and that's what
that's what's all about I think that's
why I'm but when I say I'm learning I am
I'm learning everyday I'm like why am I
not happy today why do I feel you know
what why don't you take a nice hike and
look at the beautiful [ __ ] trees and
nature and sure you're colorblind but
this guy still looks great you know I
mean there's so many things you could do
every day that we just go oh I'm tired
I'm this and just you get a car go for a
drive up the coast or I mean and
wherever you live there's always
something you can do to just go take it
outside and when you get outside of your
head when you could just say because
that's not fun to be in there too much
too long but if you just take a you know
today I'm picking the day off I'm just
gonna hang out Leo and Cortney and we're
gonna go to Chuck E Cheese [ __ ] I don't
want to go there but I'm gonna go just
to see Leo's face and those bacteria
infested balls at he's playing he's you
know there's that that's where you know
people talk about meditation and I don't
have a regular meditation practice I
still I can't I still have not had this
found the structure to do that in my
life but I've read a lot about it I've
read a lot of books of spirituality and
religion and all they do this man you
can do it trust me and and I do have you
know moments where I'm meditating in
life just in just in life let's honest
setting aside time to do it but my point
bringing this up is clearing your mind
is one thing but listening to your mind
is is is maybe another thing and when
you're in nature you can be in nature
but you also have to
be aware of where your thoughts are and
and surrender to the fact that you're in
nature and that you don't need to write
the email and that you don't know don't
think if that's it isn't it think about
what's [ __ ] think about what's for
dinner or check your Twitter messages
because if you have another follower if
you just but those but we that's the
autopilot that's so it's so quietly
running these programs running in the
background that it's really challenging
we start to cultivate the the ability to
listen to it now I'm saying this not
because I've mastered it because I am
currently working on it and as you're
talking to somebody even can I talk to
you and still have that awareness amount
over sharing or why am i sharing this
information and I do that because I with
my son can I really when I go to the
park with him and he wants to play with
me can I just surrender and not worry
about anybody watching me and saying oh
no that's brain around there's one
thought that pops into my head sometimes
the other it is oh I have this email I
have to get back to my mana drafting my
if something texted me of what would it
got what are we having for dinner yeah I
have to let go of those things in order
to really be with him fully and play and
engage and then I can get back my
childlike sense and and really just play
with him and that's really a challenge
it's not a challenging but you probably
get down on yourself like why it be no
why because this is honestly this is
just as bad as a cocaine addiction okay
yeah because it really is
or a heroine maybe I mean maybe we won't
die as fast maybe it doesn't feel like
it's [ __ ] you up really badly but it
is it's almost as if one thing leads to
another 2-3 hours of a wasted day - man
I could have I could have been having a
great hike with my friend or I could
have been it just sucks the life out of
you and it's it's hard and it's but why
do I have to keep coming back because
you're addicted to it we're addicted to
it this is its that's the world we live
in and so but we again like a coke
addict like a heroin addict guess what
we got the [ __ ] choice we can say you
know what I don't touch you today and
guess what when I pick you up tomorrow
the world won't end mm-hmm it just won't
I might have 40 emails you know what
tomorrow I'll take four hours and I'll
just get caught up in everything but
today no phone be present and you know
what I had that yesterday for a lot of
the day where I was just distracted from
doing things I had a went to the Ronald
McDonald House with the kids for three
hours I went to this other day
no no 85% of my day was like I couldn't
really be on the phone you know and that
when I looked at it I saw these messages
I go what I really missing oh my friend
kara said what are you doing
okay sorry I was just being busy
you know you don't anything how do we
feel so compelled to respond to
everything yeah I always I don't wanna
hurt people's feelings yeah hey I'm in
town what are you doing I don't have to
respond do you do you feel like you're
on the flow to my mom you feel like you
something you know Flynn the flow what
people call the flow yesterday or the
fizz out it is the flow there's
something called I mean that's when you
get creative you know people talk about
when they do daring things and they're
surfing or you know hang gliding or all
kinds of they get in the flow but but
it's just like ease and there wasn't
ease you know I have like the horrible
neck issues from the fusion I mean
they're getting a lot better but I
notice when I'm connected or when I'm
use a good way when I'm not on my phone
because you know they have this epidemic
or people looking at their phones you
know and that people are growing like
tails and their sigh and [ __ ] I mean
this is true this science look it up but
by the way how if you have neck problems
should you be like this should you be
[ __ ] looking down like that I mean we
just do it but yes I in the in the zone
in the would you call it the flow I mean
I just want to get more in the flow of
life but you know I said to myself I
wrote down go away and I named a couple
places you want to go here you're gonna
go here and I'm always waiting around
like well let's see my friend can get
off work and go with me hey why don't
you just [ __ ] go by yourself you
[ __ ] loser who can't be by yourself
go to [ __ ] Italy by yourself for a
week I don't know what if I die then you
die in Italy that's pretty cool I mean
why can't you just [ __ ] be go take a
break turn your phone off go to get a
hotel somewhere er in Santa Monica and
just go on the beach anywhere just
disconnect it's so easy to do and I keep
pushing it three weeks four weeks it's
like I'm gonna put a date in my calendar
after this interview I'm gonna say if
you don't go by this date it's over I
hate you that's what I'm gonna say you
know people go on vacation and they can
have that reprieve a lot of the time we
don't go on vacation enough and it's
something that you can do I think
probably on a daily basis is checking in
and having that mental I'm already
called mental vacation I
I it's it's it's understanding the pole
of purpose you'll go back to purpose and
drive and work and kids and attachment
to all of these things in the social
structure that is life that we have to
experience if we're just laying on the
beach all day I think you really would
get bored of that to a degree so that's
why people who get sunburn cancer right
your attire they've often find they need
something else to do because sitting at
home by it all the time to play World of
Warcraft I'd get bored and lonely at
some point I would want real human
interaction and I would need to go out
and do something so it's a balance
between structure and non structure that
we have to that we have to that we can
push push towards I guess is is is
working I don't want to not be working
but it's it's doing the work it's going
to work doing something useful that that
hopefully benefits society in some way
but I'm not killing myself to do it I'm
having joy while I'm doing and I'm
finding a way to be an awareness as I'm
doing everything I'm doing in life you
know what I just thought of maybe this
isn't profound when it came to me it
felt profound when were on these things
and when we're so preoccupied with all
these it's because in the back of our
[ __ ] feeble minds Brandon what we're
thinking about is once I get to where I
don't have to care about this once I
have such I have enough money or success
or this thing that I love this podcast
gets enough listeners then I could rule
it it's always going after something
that's intangible that is like it's
never gonna end then when it's bigger
than what then it's harder if you don't
learn to do it now it's you're never
gonna learn it exactly that is very
profound I mean it's a different way
that that that is the experience we're
all doing it in a different way now we
all had different parents we all went to
you know have different friendships we
all have different jobs and different
relationships with the people that I
work but we're all living a human
experience we all have there's different
social economical economic you know
status and all of that but
we all are challenged by the same things
and the choice is do you want to
continue living like that just a choice
or so would you like to investigate a
different way of being so that you can
be at peace with where you are presently
that's it
I agree I think that that's why I think
we all want everyone can relate anyone
who's listening we want peace we want to
just know we were a great friend great
father whatever it is it's just knowing
like I am enough but yet money's not
gonna do it
look at Tom Steyer for instance he's
just popping into my brain because I saw
him on The Colbert the other day
this guy's a billionaire he's not at
peace no he's fighting for what he
believes is the right of the country
he's billionaire no political you know
not in politics and he says I'm gonna
run for president because I I can't I
don't agree with what's happening and
maybe I can contribute maybe I can help
now all those things but but he's not if
money gave him peace of mind he'd be on
a beach gives all this money to charity
every year and now he's and now he's
running families run so money doesn't
buy you that's just like that's taller
oh that's altruism that's like
philanthropic at another level when you
have you could disappear you could own
the half the earth and what you're
trying to do is just be a better human
being make the world better that why I
think because it's exciting that and in
that life is if we're doing the same
thing all the time and you have a piece
and it's boring not saying that this
should always be war at strife to make
that life interesting but we have to
have challenges in our life we want
challenges we strive for challenges and
we strive for challenges we don't think
we know we're doing it but but that's
exciting mm-hmm if you play a video game
where you just wander around and you
don't aren't aren't aren't challenged by
anything this is a free play of a world
it's fun yeah but I think that you
eventually want to be challenged by by
something in order to have the
experience
be worthwhile have the experience be
interesting and also to learn from
yourself om love you're not challenged
that's great that's what I want to do I
want to be in love I just want to be in
love yeah that sounds stupid but I do I
think it'd be awesome to just be just
crazy about something something I'm not
crazy about people just that you know
when you can trust someone
wholeheartedly in just a relationship I
really get it's been a while since I've
had that kind of you know I think that
goes back to you too though man the band
u2 hey it's great it goes maybe
somewhere to them your capacity to love
someone else is your capacity to love
yourself and sincerity and and the depth
which you can accept and love yourself
as is that with which you can do to the
other person I think and that's
something I've had to learn an
experience as well I'm sure it's also
not always about you and I you need
someone to sort of say hey [ __ ] turn
your phone off spend time with your
family go oh my god you know sometimes
you need somebody who's also accountable
you could you know they could help you
though you're accountable for your own
it but also someone else's life is not
meant to be lived alone damnit
if you I don't mean the you can be as
you can be single but you if you're not
if you don't have other people in your
life reflecting back who you are
that's a memory so that you can't learn
anything in the process of being here
also is is you have to have to just like
you have to have black and white you
have to have more than one person more
than one thing in order to know know who
you are
mmm help you figure out who you are to
bounce yeah you have to you have to yes
you know I apologize to you I apologize
for the beginning of the interview I
felt like it was just too intense mm-hmm
I felt like we just jumped into it
because I wanted to talk to you about
like you know I had toys around the
house and like you know you guys just
got a house and and you know you're like
you want a toy room you want some
because you have toys to you were being
Superman you had Underpants not
Underpants uh pajamas Janis yeah
I call them Underpants sometimes a part
of that they're kind of a costume but
you had all this do you you what kind of
- what's your favorite toy that you have
I don't say I'm a collector like looking
around your eye I'm not a I collect I
have the toys of the things that I've
because people send them to me and
there's kind of a unique thing so I
don't I wouldn't say I'm a collector of
a a true collector of memorabilia that
much but I do have some cool things I
have I mean I have a Joe Montana signed
football did say that's a beautiful
that's probably my biggest I'm not a I'm
not a Giants fan but I'll never forget
that team I love Montana and Dwight
Clark and it just yeah go ahead go ahead
so that was a pretty that's a pretty
special thing for me then I'd like to be
able to put up and have a room to
display in the movie posters and all of
the projects the various the cool props
and things that I might have that people
people have made to me yeah just to go I
get all these wonderful things that
people make for me yeah man they're just
you know some of them end up sitting in
a box and I'd like to build display and
say oh this is cool I mean that's nice
um although it's hard to put up too many
things of yourself because that looks
just it's just that's that's good I do
that way but I think what we're gonna do
is we're gonna incorporate some of those
things into that into the house in in a
way in a cool way and not be so not that
we were ever really strict about how we
you know the art we put up on in our
house but but be more just free with it
so we put this and this is art and
here's a poster of the show and here's
this and that here's a picture of our
family and this and just kind of have it
more be more
I don't know unique the the family it's
like this is our house this is the my
house or your house it's our house this
is you know not a museum it's just a
family he's saying you seen this as a
museum no no no I think that's a me I'm
saying order now
what the [ __ ] did that what he said
hoarder this is eclectic that's what I
mean thank you I think that would be
that word for it we're gonna do
something real quick for I I do this
every episode the last end of the
episode it's for my patrons they get to
ask some questions here and this is
called [ __ ] talkin ok Rosenbaum Danny
says I think he's great at playing
comedic scenes so I'd like to know which
movie makes him laugh the most which
movie in in the history of life um I'm
gonna go with my favorite comedy is
probably Monty Python Holy Grail
it's great
I love that I cut your I cut your
freakin leg off I'll bleed all over you
I don't remember all right Nico P when
preparing for a role like Superman how
do you make the role your own without
crossing the line into imitating a
previous incarnation I'm sure you've
been asked that a lot
yeah and again these are quick questions
you don't have to answer the you know
you know just you'd be quick if you want
okay
essentially I was tasked with kind of
having the similar energy of Christopher
Reeve and Superman Returns and so I I
did do that and partially that was just
in me because having watched the film so
many times and he was my Superman so it
was just innately there
I had absorbed absorbed it I guess to a
degree and then you know I I did I
played Clark differently I think in some
ways my my my approach to him wasn't was
was certainly different than then
Chris's but there are there are
similarities and there are things that
are there different so it I'm not afraid
to to have walked in his footsteps
because I said I was tasked with I think
that that's that's true especially there
going well he resembles there's a
resemblance Kent if they're saying that
I wouldn't have had that you don't want
you to get there going hey I'm told I
wouldn't have that I wouldn't have
gotten the job right didn't do some of
that
jillee I love Brandon I think he does an
amazing job at playing characters that
are good and still making them
entertaining does he get tired of
playing the good guy well you play bad
guys I don't get tired I love the good
guy I never get to play the talking
about the joy and and the experience of
life and the balance you know I that's
why I love playing Clark and and Ray
Palmer so much Clark was was able to be
human and to live as a human on earth
because he couldn't do it as Superman so
he it was great joy and I interacting
with people and that's why he was happy
and all of these things and and Ray
Palmer is it has a similar approach
about life as well he he believes in
goodness and and happiness and all those
things but his journey on legends has
been with the entrance of Courtney's
character Nora dark to see the other
side and to find balance and kind of
burying my own life Angie
difficult to keep a straight face acting
he beside Justin Long and Zach and marry
me absolutely I'm sure I I ruined a
couple of good improv lines that he had
when that happened because I couldn't
he's hilarious he's coming on the show
too oh yeah good
Casey other than yourself who's your
favorite wait not Casey I'm not asking
Casey Casey says other than yourself
who's your favorite Superman oh well I
love myself
I was your favorite super Christopher
Reeve hey yeah Matthew J what were your
thoughts on Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
where you played a crazy powerful vegan
ex-boyfriend I'm curious what you think
of the role looking back now that it's
been so many years it's a fantastic film
I think it you know I still get many
many fans who come up and are very
appreciative and quote the line and a
quote the lines from the movie it was so
much fun Edgar Wright as a genius
the whole cast and crew was a fun to
work on and I love playing outrageous
out there over-the-top characters Ryan
do you know what quote from that movie
uh I can't think of any codes but
follow-up deed actually play the bass I
learned to play the bass a bit for that
to play that you play a trumpet the bass
battle Peter no but yeah play bass you
ballet I play trumpet in middle school
and playing the pep band in college oh
nice I'm playing high school I did flee
in high school too but yeah I mean he
had jazz band yeah I wasn't I was in
jazz band I was in marching band I
didn't end up doing marching band in
college which is because I didn't work
on my schedule but my dad is a jazz
drummer and so I quit listening to a lot
of jazz Gerry dub you how did you like
working with Brian singer
you took a deep breath in that one well
there there's uh you're trying
challenging it's a challenging subject
madhavi's obviously with the the current
right but like brian in visit is a film
genius and was very passionate about the
film and i think made a great a great
movie was not always easy to work with
why wasn't it easy to work with
i mean we were talking about the mental
health mmm
everyone should be seeing a therapist
everyone has trauma in their life and
when I say trauma
it just means emotional experiences
heavy emotional experiences that doesn't
mean you had a traumatic brain injury or
that you were in the war everyone has
had some kind of trauma in their life
everyone should be seeing a therapist I
recommend a trauma therapist I see one
and he had things in his life which you
know would come up and he wasn't always
the the kindest person to everyone he
was always put on his best face for me
thankfully so he was kind to you that
was not that was not but you saw it you
witnessed other things that you were
like that's uncomfortable
Angelina gee before beginning work in
the industry what is the one film or
show you wish you would have had the
chance to be in before working in if you
look back and go oh before let's on at
this time kind I'd love to be on thirty
something was that on that was way over
by that for me before the industry hips
thirty something now I'm forty eight
something before I was in yeah what was
the one film or TV show you like God man
I'd love to be in that how many years
ago did you start the industry let's
figure it out then Twenty twenty years
ago so that was ninety nine I moved out
to LA I mean I one of my first auditions
was for Dawson's Creek ooh and I'm not
not not as a regular it was a character
that had like in season three years
right so I would kind of watch that I'm
like oh I'm gonna go because I
technically wasn't in it yet I wouldn't
say that was a huge dream but it
the first time I I never thought about
that so if I it's a conscious thought
about being on I was like what if I was
on Dawson's Creek and don't you love
that song I used to hate it when I was
oh yeah now yeah was it yeah I was like
am I gonna go lower then that's gonna
sound stupid I don't stick ooh I went
for the original key last to be over
that was a good song that Hussein I made
each other penny isn't a penny no penny
there was a penny look it out Brian well
I'm asking the next question okay we're
almost done taylor be what movie or show
or do you feel your greatest
accomplishment why I always kind of lean
towards soup grant because it was the
biggest most pivotal experience not just
you know career-wise but but but just
personally you know it everything has
stemmed from from that experience all
right by the way did you like working
with Kevin Spacey shut up I'll shut up
but you know I didn't think about that
he was Lex Luthor movie yeah dude holy
cold Paula koala cold just check for
shits and giggles it for middle name is
penny there's a ban of something a penny
something and I yeah uh no you can see
that that's not I love the look you just
gave me last guess or something last I
guess that's them Deon K or some of the
funniest moments on the set of Chuck
great friend I love that show I was a
fan of that show before going on uh
funny moments funny funny funny you know
I always loved being in the buy more
that was I was wanted to be in the buy
more more but my character was the bad
guy turned you know good guy turned bad
guy so I didn't wasn't there very much
doing funny stuff but I don't always had
fun when we were there Oh
funniest and yeah funniest Lisa I love
him in loves ingredients I love him in
legend says Lisa thank you Lisa
a question would be in regards to your
current role mm-hm what has been your
favorite air era era mm-hmm because I
know there's like the Smallville error
or there's this era right right
historical events slash that legends
have black yes so that's kind of that
would count right the crossovers kind of
yeah yeah okay so what is your favorite
well I'm I just be the
when we in season two went back to like
five 600 AD
not yea ad uh Camelot we did in a
Camelot episode and I was you see was
knighted sorcerer raiment of the palm
did you love it it did
I got to swordfight just dressed up like
a stud neal mcdonough
do you love me yeah yeah remember he was
on that he's great he's he's he's such a
Fanta yeah well he's got a lot of kids
yes I think she's a fantastic actor he
is really he played Courtney's dad in
the show and they had you know Nora and
and damien darhk's relationship was was
awesome and i got to be a part of some
fun stuff with him he's he's great by
the way have you finished filming out
you're done yes I finished in November
in November so that's it yeah
was it an emotional finish did you cry
in front of the crew were they upset
people because I feel like they love you
I did cry a little bit there's it was a
weird schedule because we were filming
the crossover as I was filming my last
two episodes so it's hard defenders oh
we're going back and forth and crossover
days two episode days and there's a very
dramatic very dramatic scenes in the
last couple episodes and when a
particular between Nick Zano and I and
you know it was that that was that was
the hardest though there's the hardest
day and I got a lot of my emotions out
that day on set on set on camera I bet
they came pretty easily it was there it
didn't have to reach far for it and so
the last day I was you know in the atom
suit doing green screen working by
myself with the crew so it was a little
bit kind of a weird last day I bet when
that makeup artist should give it a hug
when she kind of did you go in there cuz
I remember I used to have my head
cleaned up cuz [ __ ] took two hours in
the beginning to do everything right you
know they figured it out I ended up
taking an hour and a half after it's
like two years of because it was that
you couldn't see hair line I so much
hair so they shave me is you know and
then all the and then at the end it took
a half an hour to get it all off in warm
towel and just like you know and I
remember the last time and I was kind of
come you know it's great it says the
crew clapped and I hugged everybody and
you know I was just ready to go I was
just ready I was like yeah and as I'm
walking out I looked at Natalie I looked
at her and I just fell apart and I just
started crying and she cried and I held
her because this woman I knew her by far
more than I've known anybody in my life
yeah I was with her all day seven years
ten months a year twenty two episodes a
year and it was just in that makeup
trailer for two hours talking about her
life I know all her stories and her me
talking she seemed good bad everything
it was just this emotion that poured out
and what was great was kind of
bittersweet wasn't I left you know it
was a couple years ago I had this show
called him pastor that was on for just a
couple years and I got her to come work
on the show and some other crew guys
from Smallville and I got yeah this was
nice to see them back because they were
people don't realize they're like family
it's like you're with them more than
your family family I mean that's the
hardest thing we there were a couple of
people that that happened to me kind of
a surprise like oh well there's that
okay there's some strong emotion and the
actors that you just felt like see they
would notice no what they were there
were no it was I was by myself
oh yeah the green screen so so it was
just the crew DP probably yes I mean he
was trying to hold it together because
he had or our first a cam operator you
know he had to keep it together and do
the rest of the work and but with with
makeup and hair especially that's you
know you know I'm sure with your wife
that bond and she wasn't there but but
but our first day for our last days
together we were having emotions
together because of our last scenes
together and you know it's just a I've
never I've never been in that position
before and again leaving wasn't my
choice
so there's all of those feelings mixed
up in there and nobody wanted to my
knowledge nobody on the crew wanted to
see me go so and they they knew that
that's because they didn't see on the
road rage
because they were watching the road rage
from eight years ago yeah so I take that
experience and I'm very grateful for it
and I have to be ready
I'll pack tossing all the things that
I've been talking about the school this
whole conversation is having that be a
part of my story that is part of my
experience and when I start to ruminate
on that I have to go okay but leave it
there for now because it's not gonna put
usually not gonna put me in a good place
and you can't control it and I can't
control it anymore I can control my
response and my responses to go okay I'm
thinking about it now how can I best
serve myself and my family in this
moment right thinking about that are
moving on and finding the presence to be
with my son or my wife well you said
something before you're grateful I'm
grateful that you came on the show today
Thanks I'm grateful for having you I
thought this was really fun and
insightful and I mean I think look I
think you're a great guy I think what's
great is your you just you you're you're
very honest with yourself and other than
to be because I don't think I always
have that that's all it is the fact that
you're working on it yeah just to admit
that hey I'm haven't been the greatest
in the past at times I have it I think
people are very forgiving it's just
about who you are now who you're
becoming and I think that's what I'm
striving for I think we all are so we
have to give everybody a chance to grow
and to become themselves obviously you
can still be at fault for things nearthe
to make up for those mistakes and there
are ways to do that but if we never
allow anybody to grow outside of
themselves then then what the heck you
know this so guys give me a chance to
doom to no chance you have you heard
Brandon give Michael a well off to give
you yeah did thank you for allow me to
be inside of you ah thank you it's been
a pleasure I love that episode that was
the first one on video so I hope you
guys enjoyed that that I mean a good job
the couch is different the counselor
wants to point that out different couch
we have a different couch now because
Brandon was sitting on a different couch
we got a new couch here look right now
Ryan great job on the first episode of
ever editing a podcast thank you I think
you did a great job and I know you spent
a lot of time in this and I probably
don't pay you enough but eventually I
will if I can
Ford you I do it for the love yeah I
think you do I hope you do and I and I
love you look this is all part of like
you know you work hard in the beginning
we work hard and and hopefully things
come you know we grow together yeah all
of us we grow together we do top patrons
out there shout out to the top tier
patrons who support the podcast Allison
L Andrew see Angelina G barielle Bob
Bieber Tex Chris Dion k Emily K Emily s
Emma H Jason D Jason W Jerry W Jill E
Kevin our cab Kristin K is that Kristin
Kreuk she's supporting us that'd be neat
Lauren G Lee s Kylie uh just kidding
mark a Michael s Nancy D Nico Raj Robert
B CeraVe Scott be Sean w Tiana Trisha n
Yuki go and remember check out the the
live podcast in Austin tell me if you're
coming we need you there there's limited
seating Zack Levi is the guest go on my
social media and you'll see where you
can get tickets and all that and I said
it in the intro if you for some reason
didn't listen to the intro but and then
I'm gonna be in Mexico and doing a lot
of cons this year so see if I'm in a
city near you and you can come up and
say oh my god a listen inside you and
I'll be like ah dude and we'll hug each
other just like that yeah we will shout
out to my um charities Ronald McDonald
House echos of hope for foster youth
food on foot for homeless if you ever
feel like donating that's great thank
you for being coming a patreon and
supporting inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum and all these wonderful things
that were giving you I think that's
about it I think we should shut the f
option we shut it down let's shut it
down thank you allow me to be inside of
you take care if you have any ideas or
anything we're always open to hearing
your ideas and I'm on the Cameo thing
and doing all that stuff so thanks
thanks for listening and subscribe tell
your friends about it retweet share it
all that's gonna really help and we want
to keep doing this for you
and keep doing it for us because we love
it so figure
[Music]